social media companies target Alex Jones
Trump goes up off on the Trump Tower
meeting tariffs and LeBron and the left
continues to defend racism so long as
it's directed against white people I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man we have so much to get to today
it was a very full weekend of Trump
tweets and more Trump tweets and then
even more charm - it's a stir that I
don't mind you I think we're only about
a week away from our big live event so
if you're gonna go check out those
last-minute tickets now is the time at
daily wire calm slash events go check
those out also it is imperative that you
think about the quality of the air that
you are breathing there's this article
that I saw last week about how air
pollution in national parks is as bad as
the top 20 major cities in the United
States probably that's Trump's fought
but the reason apparently is because
these parks are downwind of air
pollution sources like agriculture
industry major highways and urban areas
so basically there's now nowhere to run
except inside we know the indoor air
quality is actually worse very often
than the air quality outside which is
one of the reasons why you need to go to
filter by calm and keep a fresh set of
filters in your home central air system
and at the office we use filter by comm
here at the daily wear offices I use it
at my house as well
filter by is America's leading provider
of HVAC filters for homes and small
businesses the hell over 600 sizes that
ship for free within 24 hours plus
they're manufactured right here in the
United States I recommend you set up
auto delivery also so you don't forget
to regularly switch up your filters like
I normally do but now I no longer have
to worry about it because the filters
just arrive regularly plus they knock
five percent off the order when you sign
up save time save money breathe better
whether it's filter by calm that's
filter bu why.com filter by comm and
tell them I sent you again filter by
comm go check them out make your air
quality cleaner okay so big story over
the weekend is that Apple and Facebook
have now targeted Alex Jones over at
Infowars for those who don't know who
Alex Jones says he's a crazy human so
Alex Jones his craze extends to
believing that there was a there was a
pizza shop in Washington DC that was
associated with Hillary Clinton that was
running pedophiles from it or somesuch
he also has suggested that the Sandy
Hook massacre was actually a ret a false
flag that it was a bunch of child actors
he has suggested that Seth rich was
murdered by Hillary Clinton I believe I
think he was involved in the South Ridge
stuff as well there very few conspiracy
theories in which Alex Jones does not
engage most famously he believed he has
said in the past that he believes that
the government is turning the frogs gay
by somehow changing the chemical
composition in the water he's most
famous for
his emotional outbursts on his show so I
will say that Alex Jones is wildly
entertaining in the same way that WWE
Raw is wildly entertaining and for many
of the same reasons he screams and he
yells and he sounds somewhat like Hulk
Hogan and he and he does not have ho ho
goons who takes off his shirt anyway and
he's really just a giant bag of lunacy
well he has a very large following
because conspiracy theories are in fact
extraordinarily popular when people are
seeking to place order on chaos they
look to conspiracy theories there a lot
of people who are big names
followers of Alex Jones most famously
the President of the United States used
to call in regularly to Alex Jones and
saw Alex Jones as a quasi ally Alex
Jones claimed that after the election
President Trump was calling him fairly
regularly Jones as I say is a toxic
personality I of the highest order he
and I have gotten into it in the past
that actually ended with him doing a
weird imitation of me well which I will
play for you in a few minutes here but
here's what Facebook and Apple are
saying so Facebook and Apple have now
banned him they're clamping down on him
suffice it to say that well I think that
Alex Jones is basically a giant dumpster
fire of human that he smells like the
burning garbage that that aerates the
the scent of New York City I think that
Alex Jones should not be banned from
Apple and Facebook simply because the
standards that are being used by the lot
of these social media companies are
extraordinarily vague Apple and Facebook
according to CNBC have now clamp down on
content by Alex Jones Monday
the former pulled five of his podcasts
the latter removed four pages controlled
by him Apple confirmed on Monday had
removed five of the six podcasts which
included Jones infamous the Alex Jones
Show as well as a number of other
Infowars audio streams the news was
originally reported by BuzzFeed news
Jones of course is a controversial
conspiracy theorist who is claimed that
the 2012 Sandy Hook shooting was a hoax
hoax and has been hit with other content
bans from YouTube as well as Spotify
Apple's move is pretty dramatic they've
taken down the entire library of
Infowars podcasts rather than a select
few episodes an apple spokesperson said
quote Apple does not tolerate hate
speech and we have clear guidelines that
creators and developers must follow to
ensure we provide a safe environment for
all of our users podcasts that violate
these guidelines are removable from our
directory making them no longer
searchable or available for download or
streaming we believe in representing a
wide range of views so long as those
people are respectful to those with
differing opinions so they say that he
persistently uploaded content in breach
of various content guidelines Facebook
says the same in July Facebook removed
four of Jones's videos and hit his own
personal profile with a 30-day ban over
what the firm deemed is violation of its
policies on bullying and hate speech the
company explained that when it deletes
content the removal counts as a strike
essentially a warning against the person
that uploaded it in the first place in
the case of pages facebook said it holds
both a page and an administrator who
post content in violation of its rules
accountable they said that this was not
about fake news they said this is not
because of Jones's tendencies toward
conspiracism instead it was about hate
speech and bullying they said well much
of the discussion around Infowars has
been related to false news which is a
serious issue we are working to address
by demoting links marked wrong by fact
checkers and suggesting additional
contents none of the violations that
spurred today's removals were related to
this so it is again unclear what exactly
it was that triggered all of this they
say that it was it was his threatening
language but again I would need to see
the specific threatening language that
he was using and I'm somebody who's been
threatened by Alex Jones mean Alex Jones
has legitimately gone on his show and
threatened that he would send his
buddies down to the the people who
helped fund Daily wire that he would
send those people down to their their
ranch in Texas and have them harassed I
mean Alex Jones a bad guy but the
problem is this once you start saying
that hate speech is a rationale for
banning people from social media you get
into some very very vague territory
because as we know the left does not
have a consistent standard that they
uphold when they are looking at hate
speech they don't say that anything that
is hateful is banned and then defined
hateful in extraordinarily specific
terms they don't say anything that is
offensive is banned because a lot of
things are offensive instead they use
this term hate speech to simply label
stuff they don't like hate speech I know
this because I've been targeted Matt by
social media per se but by a lot of
folks on the Left who suggest that I am
some sort of provocateur involved in
hate speech what exactly have I said
that is hate speech well their favorite
is that I don't use preferred pronouns
so if somebody like Caitlyn Jenner says
that Caitlyn Jenner is a woman I will
still say the Caitlyn Jenner is a man
and I will say Caitlyn Jenner is a he
right this is hate speech according to a
lot of folks on the left well what's to
prevent Apple or Facebook from removing
content online simply because I don't
abide by their standards they're rumors
today that a lot of these social media
Giants are gonna start banning or
restricting content from people who they
deem climate change deniers not even
people who acknowledge that that climate
change is happening but worried that it
may not be happening to the same extent
that some on the Left say and don't look
like the left solutions those people may
not be safe from the predations of
social media also so again what is the
exactly what exactly is so terrible the
company said it removed
Alex Jones's pages for glorifying
violence which violates our graphic
violence policy and using dehumanizing
language to describe people who are
transgender Muslim and immigrants which
violates our hate speech policies again
this is where we get into some serious
serious issues what exactly violates
that hate speech policy so if I say that
transgender people have mental disorders
which they do ok gender dysphoria or
gender identity disorder is as you may
have noticed from the term gender
identity disorder a disorder if you say
that is that no hate speech what if I
say that while not all Muslims are
terrorists a disproportionate number of
terrorists are Muslim is that hate
speech because that is also a fact what
if I say that immigrants coming to the
United States
you know ought to be vetted because we
don't know who's violent and who is not
is that hate speech I don't think it is
that anything even comes close to hate
speech but one of the big problems is
that you have too many folks on the Left
who decide that anything they don't like
now is is hate speech and they're not
and I'm not again one of the things
that's very weird about this is that I
really dislike Alex Jones his brand I
think that Alex Jones is a liar I think
he's a conspiracist I think he does say
horrible things and hateful things on a
regular basis but there is no consistent
standard that you can set there is no
limiting principle to Facebook or Apple
and their social media guidelines other
than trust us and I'm sorry I don't
trust you guys I don't trust you guys
and just to demonstrate again that I'm
not saying this out of some perverse
love for Alex Jones Alex Jones hates my
guts and I think that he is if I've not
made clear a flaming pile of human feces
here's Alex Jones mocking me on his show
like two weeks ago
I think I'll get your business you know
what happens when I get in people's
businesses boy they ain't in business
long son you like what I did to your
daddy bet you really did it to himself
didn't he we told everybody what he was
okay so that weirdo right was
threatening me on his show and I'm now
defending his show clearly I'm a bad guy
he it's it's just dangerous stuff I
think it's it's deeply dangerous stuff
to have so many folks on the Left trying
to determine what content constitute
eight speech the reason that I think
that it's deeply dangerous and the
reason I don't trust them is because
there is a massive double standard when
it comes to the left and for example
racism so when I suggest that hatred of
a particular race is the definition of
racism people on the Left will say well
it depends on the race so for example
there's an article in The New York Times
this week
all about why calling white people
racist may not actually be the most the
best possible way of curbing racism and
this article drew all sorts of hatred
from folks on the political left the
article was an opinion piece by a woman
named Margaret rankle and what it said
was they're still white Southerners who
honestly believed that American culture
worked better for everyone white and
black alike under segregation they're
still white Southerners who questioned
how bad slavery really was when an
enslaved black person's health and
strength are needed to guarantee the
slaveholders livelihood this argument
goes it just wouldn't make sense to whip
them or starve them a rape them and work
them to the point of collapse
southerners aren't alone in believing
such mendacity but the south is where
slavery and segregation metastasized so
it may be more concentrated here
whatever this insidious delusion takes
hold however it requires a gargantuan
ignorance of history to maintain and
there's a lot of ignorance a foot in the
land right now more people in Tennessee
today drive cars bearing license plate
it's emblazoned with the Confederate
battle flag than ever before a strong
majority of southerners 61% are
committed to keeping their Confederate
monuments on public land I've exhausted
my ability to understand why deep into
the 21st century I'm still hearing
otherwise good-hearted people use the
same arguments white Southerners used to
discredit Uncle Tom's Cabin more than
150 years ago it couldn't possibly have
been that bad maybe this is what happens
when a person's only news source is the
alternative universe of Fox and Friends
or maybe they're all just racists okay
they're definitely all races so this is
it you know very leftist article but
it's coming under fire from the left why
because here is the point they don't
believe they are and the problem with
writing off people who don't recognize
this country's pervasive and enduring
culture of white supremacy much less the
ways in which they themselves benefit
from it is simple being called a racist
almost never causes a racist to wake up
being called a racist to almost never
causes a racist to say oh wow you're
right
I get that it's hard not to scream
racist at a racist if you're a white
person who wants to be an advocate it's
both infuriating and demoralizing to
know that the people causing all the
suffering are people who look just like
you here's what is also true prejudice
is endemic to humanity itself human
beings are tribal creatures we trust the
familiar and are drawn to it we just
trust the unfamiliar and keep our
distance
white people liberal and conservative
often claimed not to notice another
person's race but it's just not true
we are hardwired to recognize difference
and to view it as an aberration noticing
difference is not the same thing as
hating difference of course but I'm not
just talking about vicious white
supremacist here I'm talking about
garden-variety prejudice and the answer
that this lady says is maybe yelling
racist at people is not actually a good
idea because when you yell racist to
people all you are doing is alienating
people this author says take a breath
when you encounter a person who believes
he's merely honoring his ancestors by
driving a car with an image of the
Confederate battle flag on the tag when
a Facebook friends announces it's
disrespectful to take a knee during the
national anthem when you sit down next
to someone at a church picnic who
genuinely loves and respects the black
people they know but who consistently
votes for politicians with overtly
racist policies stop for a moment and
take a breath before you say a single
word think of all the times you made an
assumption about a stranger that proved
to be untrue think of the times you
found yourself feeling uneasy in the
company of strangers of another race not
only a reasonable article it's a fire
left article right it suggests that all
of these are elements of racism but the
best way to fight all of that is not to
yell a racist to people the left says
that this is a huge mistake make the
left says that if you yell racist did a
bunch of non racist white people that's
totally fine but if you say anything
racist about a member of another race
then it's racism I want to explain why
the Left believes this and what the
ramifications are of that in just one
second first let's talk about stamps
okay so how much time have you spent
driving down to the post office slightly
probably you've spent some well if the
answer is some the answer could be none
because no matter the great services of
the post office it's even easier at
stamps calm where you can access all of
those great services right from your
desk 24/7 when it is convenient for you
you buy and print official US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer and printer the mail
carrier picks it up you just click print
mail you're done it couldn't be easier
we use stamps calm here at the Daily
wire offices we use it at my house as
well and right now when you use promo
code Shapiro you get a special offer 555
bucks of free Post
a digital scale and a four-week trial go
to stamps calm before you do anything
else you go and you click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and you type in Shapiro that stamps comm
and you enter promo code Shapiro again
stamps calm promo codes appear and you
get that special offer it includes up to
fifty five bucks of free postage a
digital scale plus that four-week trial
the services of the post office right
there at your desk makes it really
really simple again stamps calm promo
code Shapiro stamps icon click on that
radio microphone at the top of the page
and use promo code Shapiro okay so
there's this article in The New York
Times in which it says maybe you don't
want to call all the way people racist
and the left goes mad why shouldn't we
call all right people
all white people racists instead we
should we should point out that when
people are racist they're racist ok so
here's an article from Linda Toronto
over at The Daily Beast and this is
fascinating she says poverty doesn't
make you racist it's more than that the
exhaustion strips you have the ability
to dissemble for long so if you're
inclined toward racism already it shows
a life lived close to tears of sheer
fatigue and stress is not one in which
you can expend the energy to stop
yourself spouting your resentments or
wielding your fears as a weapon so in
other words some people choose racism
poverty doesn't cause racism but
individuals are responsible for their
own racism so why would you go easy on
white racists yeah that's an opinion
with which I have some sympathy the
problem is that the left has then
claimed that Sarah Zhang who is this new
member of the New York Times editorial
board who has literally dozens and
dozens and dozens and dozens of anti
white hate tweets on her feed right
she's been left alone by the left left
says that her brand of racism is just
fine now how do you know the left has a
double standard on this because this is
hilarious Candice Owens who is black
right a black woman she took all of
Sarah's zhang's tweets or some of them
and she replaced the word white with
black tweeted them out and Twitter
banned her for a day
Sarah song is still on Twitter Candice
Owens was tossed from Twitter for a day
Twitter called it a mistake but it's
pretty obvious that there's a double
standard and how exactly the left
approaches these issues so when we talk
about Alex Jones and whether Alex Jones
ought to be banned by Facebook or Apple
no matter how much you dislike Alex
Jones the reality is the left is never
going to consistently apply their
standards which suggests that if we have
to choose between an inconsistently
applied standard in a no standard no
standard might actually be the better
move and which is a scary place to be
because the left is so damn dishonest
about their social standards on this
sort of stuff okay meanwhile over the
weekend it was a busy weekend for the
President of the United States
particularly he decided to tweet a lot a
lot a lot many of the tweets so many
tweets so the president in the United
States and decided for some reason that
he was going to tweet out about the
Trump Tower meeting now as you recall
the Trump Tower meeting what happened in
June of 2016 this is a meeting between
Donald Trump jr. and some other members
of the Trump campaign and a woman named
Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya she's a
Russian lawyer and that meeting had
basically been prepped by a Russian
source writing to Donald Trump jr.
saying we have information or the
Russian government may have information
on Hillary Clinton would you like to get
together with an emissary of the Russian
government to hear this dirt and Donald
Trump jr. was like yeah let's do it yeah
so then they had the meeting and just to
recall the timeline after they had the
meeting the President of the United
States dictated a statement to Donald
Trump jr. in which Donald Trump jr. said
that the meeting was originally about
adoptions that it was really about
adoption policy and Russian wanting to
change adoption policy and so they had
the meeting and then it turned out that
the meeting was not about adoption
policy it was in fact about dirt getting
to her on Hillary Clinton and the
president's lawyer said that Trump
didn't know any of this that Trump was
not involved with the drafting of the
statement at all then it turned out that
Trump was indeed involved with the
drafting of the statement he in fact
dictated the statement essentially
word-for-word and then yesterday the
President of the United States tweeted
this out so he tweeted out quote fake
news reporting a complete fabrication
that I am concerned about the meeting my
wonderful son Donald had in Trump Tower
this was a meeting to get information on
an opponent totally legal and done all
the time in politics and it went nowhere
I did not know about it so the entire
world goes nuts because now President
Trump who once claimed that this meeting
was about adoptions and that he had
nothing to do with writing the
statements has now announced that he
wrote the statement and also that the
meeting was not about adoptions the
meeting was actually about getting
information on Hillary Clinton okay now
people are pointing out that the media
is overwrought on this considering that
Trump tweeted the same thing with a year
ago right here's a flashback to eat this
is from July 2017 most politicians would
have gone to a meeting like the ones on
jr. attended in order to get info on an
opponent that's politics so there he was
a year ago essentially implicitly ignore
that the meeting was in fact about
gathering info on Hillary Clinton go
back to the other tweet the the this
tweet from yesterday however I think
does say a little bit more right it's a
full admission that the meeting was to
get information on an opponent and does
raise the question as to whether Trump
knew about it in advance he says he did
not know about it but he's speaking like
he knows exactly what happened at the
meeting so this raises the second
question did he know exactly what
happened at the meeting when he wrote
this statement that was false to the
press now you do run into a couple of
questions the big question here is so
what exactly what exactly is illegal
here right what exactly is illegal and
it's not truly clear what is he legal
about any of this Glenn Beck asked me a
question on Twitter yesterday that was
very good question what he asked was if
it's illegal for Donald Trump jr. to get
information on an opponent from a source
that is not a US citizen how can the
Clinton campaign infusion GPS gather
information using a former British spy
without violation seems like a
reasonable question right how is it that
you're saying it's criminal for Donald
Trump jr. to go get information from the
Russians about Hillary Clinton but it's
not illegal for Hillary Clinton to pay
fusion GPS to go to a British spy named
Christopher steel who will then go to
Russia and then obtain Apple information
on Donald Trump right how is wanting
legal but the other is not illegal and
the answer is I'm not sure any of it is
actually illegal Eugene Volokh who is a
brilliant brilliant lawyer I think it
teaches a UCLA school of law still he
has a piece over at the Washington Post
talking about whether it is crime to do
opposition research using foreign
nationals and he essentially concludes
that it probably is not that there's
nothing in law that prevents you from
going and talking to a Chinese citizen
about the sins of your political
opponents or he gives this example he
says what happens if a Turkish dissenter
knows that there's a corrupt
relationship between President Obama and
the Turkish government and decides to
tell the opposition in presidential
election about are you just supposed to
ignore that information are you supposed
to pretend that the person didn't say it
is it collusion to work with that person
and Violet comes down on the side of
know that none of this is illegal but
Donald Trump jr. meeting with the
Russians was not in fact illegal that
getting information from the Russians
probably was not illegal I think that
that is plausible and I think that's
probably right I think it's difficult to
imagine how exactly it's illegal for
Donald Trump jr. or even Donald Trump
senior right even Trump himself to
actual
go and talk with Vladimir Putin and get
information directly now is it good is
it smart is it right is it politically
viable no I don't think that it is there
are a couple of other areas in which
illegalities could in fact be implicated
I'm gonna talk about those in just a
second first I gotta tell you about
Peter Millar okay so the clothes from
Peter Millar are just first-rate as you
know I've been working on upping my
style game and giving my closet a
makeover and Peter Millar is making all
of that happen it's easily the most
comfortable clothing I've ever worn I
mean this stuff is just supremely
comfortable but here Millar polo shirts
which I love they offer comfort and
style they're easy to take care of
they're right out of the dryer don't
have to put an iron to them then grab
for the golf course they even have sun
protection built into the shirt
Peter Millar five pocket pants are
lightweight they are highly breathable
yeah it's really hot this summer so you
want Peter Millar stuff it's made from
the highest quality pima cotton they
have comfort stretch for ease of
movement they felt like your favorite
jeans with the style to be worn anywhere
if Peter Millar's exclusive wash and
finish to enhance that softness as well
and their performance shorts are
moisture wicking breathable quick drying
their shorts are really comfortable
- although clothes aren't they're
stylish they look great and they really
feel good Peter Lara is my go-to
clothing for vacation work events the
golf course even working out I put Peter
melara on the morning and then you never
look out of place
check them out on social media at Peter
Millar and at Peter Millar golf most
comfortable clothing you're ever gonna
wear go over to Peter Maillard comm
slash Ben and you can check out some of
my Peter Millar favorites be sure to use
my link you'll receive complements free
shipping and a free hat that's Peter
Millar calm that's Peter Millar mi ll AR
comm slash Ben Peter Maillard comm slash
been used that slash pen so they know we
set you can get that complimentary
shipping and the free hat Peter Maillard
comm slash been awesome clothes just go
check it out right now okay so is there
any illegality to Donald Trump jr.
having met with this Russian lawyer now
that President Trump has admitted that
that is what exactly the meeting was
about well not unless there was
coordination regarding the underlying
crime so let's say the Donald Trump jr.
or Donald Trump senior met with Russian
lawyers and then they decided that they
were going to hack the DNC and
coordinated out that well hacking the
DNC is illegal so if you are conspiracy
or in the midst of a conspiracy to hack
the DNC that's the illegal activity
there's no evidence that this is exactly
what happened other possible areas of
illegality
unreported campaign expenditures so what
say that the Trump administration or the
Trump campaign rather paid the Russians
for the information than didn't report
it to the FEC
well that would be a violation of
campaign finance the theory that they
are using most often here though is
illegal in kind contributions unreported
from foreign sources so in other words
you've got the Russian government that
is donating information to the Trump
campaign and that acts as an illegal in
kind contribution again though I'm
unsure that's the way that the law ought
to be applied and the reason I say that
is again you have a situation where you
find out that the President of the
United States is in bed with the Turkish
government and a Turkish to censor goes
to the Opposition in the United States
and gives that information is that any
legal in-kind contribution hard to
imagine that counts as an illegal in
kind contribution people do stuff for
campaigns on a daily basis that's not
necessarily in illegal in kind
contribution and the bar is a little bit
higher than that and it should be higher
than that because the fact is that free
flow of information during a campaign is
actually a good thing we want to know
more about the candidates for whom we
are voting so what is the distinction
theoretically between Hillary Clinton
hiring fusion GPS to hire a foreign
citizens go get Oppo on Trump and Trump
jr. working with the Russians there
could theoretically be two distinctions
first distinction could be that Hillary
may not have known that fusion would use
a foreign source for Trump jr. directly
met with one and second Hillary paid
fusion GPS and apparently reported it to
the FEC so at least the FEC knew what
was going on
whereas Trump jr. didn't pay for
anything or a port but that leads to
this bizarre situation where if you pay
a foreign source for Oppo on your
opponent's that's better than just
getting it on a volunteer basis from a
foreign source so in other words it's
not clear that Trump jr. actually
committed a crime in any of this so all
of you talk about Trump jr. and Trump
admitting that this whole thing was
designed to get Oppo research on Hillary
Clinton not clear that any of that is
criminal even if it is true now is it
politically good no impeachment is a
political crime it is not a crime crime
because the president of the United
States may not even be able to be tried
in Criminal Court right that's actually
very unclear under the Constitution of
the United States
what is pretty clear however is that if
the President of the United States knew
that the Russian government was
attempting to work with him to take down
Hillary Clinton and he decided to
operate in those fears that Democrats
would would attempt impeachment they
would claim that this was enough to go
after
and Trump this is why you are seeing the
Trump teams say collusion is not a crime
saying okay you actually need a crime in
order to impeach the Democrats are just
going to impeach for whatever reason
they can get behind now where is the
actual criminal activity well Donald
Trump jr. did testify I believe under
under oath that Donald Trump seniors did
not know about the Trump Tower meeting
if it turns out that is false that's
what we call a perjury trap and now
Donald Trump jr. is in danger of perjury
and they could try to flip him against
his dad theoretically that could be a
serious problem a Trump has never
testified so none of this actually
affects Trump personally all right
there's no unless Donald Trump was
colluding with the Russians to actually
commit a crime and not just they were
giving him information about Hillary
Clinton that they were hacking Hillary
and they were doing it with Trump's
express coordination that would be a
crime anything else here is probably not
a crime now this does raise another
issue and that is obstruction so the
Muller investigation is now focusing in
on obstruction of justice they're
they're trying to suggest that President
Trump is trying to obstruct the
investigation and therefore he has
committed a crime in that sphere well
obstruction of justice
would actually require him to shut down
the investigation or stop the
investigation in some way there's no
evidence that he has done any of that
whatsoever yet and it is not in fact
obstruction of justice if the president
doesn't decide to speak with Robert
Muller it's a serious legal question
right now
as to whether President Trump if
subpoenaed by robert muller actually has
to obey the subpoena there's a case
against Richard Nixon and rich Richard
Nixon was forced to give up evidence
against himself who's forced by a court
to give up the Watergate tapes but it's
not clear per se the Supreme Court ruled
but it's not clear exactly whether Nixon
would have had to testify in front of
Congress if they had called him or if a
special investigator had called the
president whether the president would be
compelled to testify not clear at all
Jay Sekulow who's still on the
president's legal team he says the
president Trump is not going to obey
subpoenas if Robert Robert Muller
decides to go after him he may just
ignore it subpoena you file what's
called a motion to quash that will be
argued at the district court then it
would go to the court of appeals then it
would go to the Supreme Court of the
United States from the Supreme Court
Knight estates he goes back down to the
lower courts again a subpoena for live
testimony has never been tested in court
as to a President of the United States
and there's a lot of language articles
and precedent against that
so the this this is gonna be the
argument that Trump makes now is the
strongest argument he has politically
that none of this is a crime no the
strongest argument he has politically is
that you didn't know about any of it he
didn't involve himself in any of it
there was no actual collusion in any
legal or real sense if however it turns
out that there was in fact collusion
it's possible the collusion is not a
crime then we have to determine whether
the President of the United States gets
tried in an actual criminal court or
whether the proper approaches
impeachment it seems to me that
constitutionally the proper approach is
indeed impeachment that was the system
the founders set up if you could just
remove a president by having a criminal
case brought against him this would
happen to virtually every president
because it's not too hard to come up
with a in which the president committed
a crime I wrote an entire book about why
theoretically you should be able to
prosecute a president it's called the
case against Barack Obama it was about
Barack Obama's various crimes his
violations of statutory law and the
suggestion that I made is that law might
have to be changed to allow for the
prosecution of presidents but I think
that the Constitution itself is not
really designed for that you may
actually need a constitutional amendment
although all of this is a really murky
area of the law because it hasn't really
happened very often only two presidents
ever have been impeached in the house
Andrew Johnson was impeached in the
house and Bill Clinton was impeached in
the house neither of them were actually
convicted in the Senate so both of them
ended up retaining their office
obviously okay so with all of this said
though is is the President of the United
States in bad shape because well I don't
think so until the Mulla report comes
out again this is all political but it
doesn't prove the President to be
tweeting about all of us the fact that
he is tweeting out that this meeting
between Trump jr. and the Russians was
actually about gathering Oppo on Hillary
Clinton it's just not smart I don't know
what's possessing him to do this I think
he's just bored over the weekend and he
decided he's gonna tweet out a bunch of
stuff and as we will see these these
sort of stream-of-consciousness Twitter
threads from the president if you want
him to be successful folks you got you
got to root for him to stop because it's
not helping him in any way I'll give you
a couple of other examples in just a
second first let's talk about legacy box
so when's the last time you watched
those home movies right you tape those
years ago and then you stuck them in
your closet and then you forgot about
them you haven't akin them out forever
and then you've got a bunch in the
garage and those are all moldering
they're falling apart well
if you feel like there's all this stuff
in your closet you're not using instead
what you should be doing is taking all
of that and sending it to legacy box
it's a simple affordable way to get your
recorded moments digitally preserved on
DVD or thumb drives you never have to
worry about it again there's a fire in
your house you're not rushing your
closet to get boxes well tapes you just
grab the thumb drive and go here's how
it works
you love legacy box with your old tapes
film pictures audio recordings you send
it back and then you get them back in a
couple of weeks on DVD or a convenient
thumb drive ready to watch share and
relive it's just awesome
legacy box takes care of everything and
they provide updates at every step of
the process so several years ago my
parents decided they wanted to preserve
all of their family memories on DVD it
cost a fortune we looked at legacy box
my family did and it is significantly
cheaper and it's a lot easier because
you just send it off and they've got it
labeled so you know where every piece is
every step of the process go check it
out right now
over 350 thousand families have used
legacy box and for a limited time when
you go to legacy box comm slash pen and
enter my code Ben you get a 40% discount
on your order that's legacy box comm
slash Ben again legacy box com so that's
gonna get a 40% discount on your order
it's totally worth it it makes a
fantastic gift for your parents
particularly go check it out legacy box
comm slash Ben again legacy box comm
slash Ben okay so speaking of the
president's suite we're gonna get to the
president tweeting about LeBron and
tweeting about tariff since we talked
about the press there's a busy weekend
on Twitter for the president but first
we're gonna have to go over to Daily
wire comm and subscribe $9.99 a month
get two subscriptions daily wire go over
there we have all sorts of awesome stuff
happening behind the paywall at daily
wire comm and you help us bring you the
show also for $99 a year you get this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the left disappears hot or cold
tumblr go behold it enjoy it
hold it in your in your hands and you
shall experience the glory that is so
nine nine dollars year gets you that
plus I'm go over subscribe at YouTube or
iTunes and you can be part of our Sunday
special we just had David Mamet on our
Sunday special last weekend we have a
bunch of awesome guests coming up in the
next few weeks as well so go check that
out we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's let's talk about the
rest of President Trump's Twitter so he
didn't just tweet about how the Trump
Tower meeting which is now two years old
how that Trump Tower meeting was
actually about colluding with the
Russians right didn't just tweet about
that he also decided to tweet about
LeBron James he's very angry because
last week LeBron James said that
President Trump and polarized sports as
I said last week I felt that this is a
foolish statement I don't think that
it's true sports has been polarized for
a long time in this country was
polarized under Barack Obama I'm old
enough to remember when players were
coming out on the field in the NFL and
doing hands up don't shoot and when
Colin Kaepernick was kneeling for the
anthem before Trump was president so
Trump is not wrong that LeBron is wrong
but Trump then tweeted this LeBron James
has just interviewed by dumbest man on
television Don Lemon he made LeBron look
smart which isn't easy to do I like Mike
alright so he he is basically calling
Tom Lemon dumb which you know frankly he
calls everybody in media dumb like all
the time it happens all the time and
then he says that LeBron is actually
dumb as well and then he said he likes
Michael Jordan which is pretty
hysterical so now we're gonna get into a
full on greatest of all time
conversation between LeBron James and
Michael Jordan led by Donald Trump which
is going to be awesome by the way I will
take Jordan narrowly LeBron has
definitely climbed in the rankings in
any case is this is the smart is this
good well probably not however is it
racist no it's not racist it's not
racist okay for the president's called
Don Lemon dumb or LeBron James dumb or
Maxine Waters dumb no that's not racist
because a complete listing of all the
people that president Trump has called
them numbers into the millions seriously
there are fewer people the president
Trump has not called them that has
called them on planet Earth right now
and yet the media decides that all of
this is just evidence of president
Trump's racism now is this a fight that
Trump needed to pick do we really need
to have a Donald Trump versus LeBron
James fight he's the President of the
United States is this really worthwhile
Plus LeBron James is not the worst guy
right LeBron James free clean living
dude he's married to the mother of his
couple of kids he married her late but
he married her he he's building a
charter school in Cleveland that by all
accounts is pretty awesome is this
really the best move probably not but
is it racist no it's not racism this
just demonstrates how the media by
overreach make Trump's case for him that
they are biased against him here's
here's Anna Navarro titular Republican
on CNN she's made a newfound career out
of bashing president Trump which is
really just silly she I'm not sure what
makes her a Republican anymore since
she's embraced virtually every lefty
policy proposal in any case she tweeted
out Trump called Don Lemon LeBron James
and Maxine Waters dumb one is from the
south one is from Cleveland one is from
LA one is in the NBA one is on TV one is
in Congress hmm I wonder what they could
possibly have in common
oh wait and then a black hand and then
she said this on CNN if you don't see
this as racist I would ask you to please
go get your vision checked when it comes
to African Americans when it comes to
black people he seems to go to the low
IQ dumbest person in the world
attack quite often it is his go-to when
it comes to African Americans that they
are dumb okay or alternatively he calls
everyone dumb because the President of
the United States has insulted everyone
from Chuck Todd to to Jeb Bush
I mean legitimately there is it it's he
calls he calls every single person dumb
right he asked if he could have an IQ
comparison with his own Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson he calls everybody
dumb like there's there's a huge list of
insults
there are 487 people the president has
insulted on Twitter and I don't think
that that's been updated was published
in January 2016 President does this all
the time he's called Mika Brzezinski low
IQ is Mika Brzezinski black of course
not but the media always have to jump to
their favorite insults and that means
that the President of the United States
is racist now again is it worthwhile for
the President of the United States to be
attacking LeBron James and talking about
Michael Jordan no but we know that the
president is pure Isle and his Twitter
account and the fact the media feel the
necessity to overreach on all of these
issues is particularly stupid
speaking of media overreach on all of
these particular issues President Trump
tweeted versus the press he knows that
the way to get his base out is to attack
the press consistently and openly here
was President Trump tweeting out against
the press he tweeted the fake news hates
me because they are the enemy of the
PIPA only because they know it's true I
am providing a great service by
explaining this to the American paper
they purposely caused great division and
trust they can also cause war they're
very dangerous and sick okay so number
one I'm not sure it's war he's saying
that the American media caused the last
time the American media caused a war was
probably the Cuban war probably
spanish-american war in which Teddy
Roosevelt was a rough rider so it's been
probably 120 years since the media
legitimately caused a war in the United
States however and the fact that that
Trump is attacking the media as the
enemy of the people the reason he does
this is because he's a troll he's a
Twitter troll okay he's a guy who trolls
the comments and the left falls for it
every time so here's Chuck Todd saying
this rationalizes violence when you call
a group of people you authorize them the
way he's trying to do with the press
calling him sick and sort of
dehumanizing him it makes violence
against the press easier to rationalize
for some oh really I mean that that's
the big deal the violence against the
press can be rationalized where are all
the cases of violence against the press
by Trump supporters I'm just wondering
really I'm wondering because like this
morning Candace Owens and Charlie Couric
over at TP USA they were sitting in a
restaurant over in Philadelphia and a
bunch of antifoam members saw them
decided to run inside and then harass
them out of a restaurant where they
started dumping water on them here's
what that looked like and sounded like
and then they're trying to scream just
geniuses over here I do have to end them
they're pouring water on on Charlie
which is yes I'm sure that the media
have much to fear but those on the right
it's understand it's only Trump that has
made this climate it's only Trump that
has made this climate
Charlie carking countess Owens by the
way you're gonna be hard pressed to find
any two bigger Trump supporters in
America and they're the ones who are
having water pour on them for the sin of
sitting at a restaurant in Philadelphia
so look Trump knows how to troll the
press and the press fall for it every
time
still should the press should the
president be calling the press the enemy
of the people
no is it is it something the like
Abraham Lincoln sitting around 1861
calling the press the enemy of the
people
not really also fair to say Abraham
Lincoln suspended the rights of habeas
corpus in jail journalist worth noting
that as well although he was in the
middle of a civil war at the time so is
appropriate not particularly
okay so meanwhile the President of the
United States Twitter rage didn't end
there he also decided to go off on
tariffs now there's been this great
debate that has broken out amongst folks
on the right as to whether Trump is
legitimately a fan of tariffs or whether
he is not the answer is he is
legitimately a fan of tariffs the
president likes to signal on the one
hand that he wants to lower all tariffs
to zero and on the other hand that he
likes tariffs he lowered tariffs to zero
argument is actually not the one coming
from president Trump's heart the reason
I know this is because if you look at
presidents Trump's rhetoric over the
last legitimately 35 years he has always
been in favor of high trade barriers and
protectionism he's a fan of high trade
barriers and protectionism and he
tweeted out his fan hood for tariffs
over the weekend he tweeted out tariffs
are working big-time every country on
earth wants to take wealth out of the
u.s. always to our detriment I say as
they come tax them if they don't want to
be taxed let them make or build the
product in the US in either event it
means jobs and great wealth and they
continued along these lines because of
the tariffs we'll be able to start
paying down large amounts of the 21
trillion dollars in debt that has been
accumulated much by the Obama
administration while at the same time
reducing taxes for our paper at minimum
will make much better trade deals for
our country okay there are so many
things wrong with these tweets just on
an economic level that it's hard to
describe all of them let's begin with
the idea that the quote-unquote tariffs
are working big-time
there's no
evidence that the tariffs are working
big-time the only thing they are doing
is actually directing American business
out of the country he says that every
country on earth wants to take wealth
out of the United States always to our
detriment me buying a product from a
foreign company at a cheaper price is
not me being victimized by that company
that is silly towns and that company has
to reinvest in the United States which
is why some of the biggest automakers in
the United States are Toyota and Honda
as well as BMW by the way and then he
says he says as they come tax them if
they don't want to be taxed let them
make or build the product in the US and
either event it means jobs and great
wealth no it does not it does not mean
jobs in great wealth to tax the American
people by charging them higher higher
prices for the goods that they wish to
buy and then he continues with the
falsehoods here I mean just this this is
not even economically literate he says
because of tariffs we will be able to
start paying down large amounts of the
21 trillion dollars in debt that has
been accumulated in order for that to be
true what he basically has to be saying
is the amount of taxes that we take off
of foreign products right bye-bye
raising the price and then we tax a
product as it comes in we're going to
take all that money and we're going to
pay it back
to pay down the debt the problem is of
course that when you lower the economic
growth in a society which is what
tariffs also do you take in less income
tax and less sales tax so there's no
evidence that tariffs are going to
outweigh the economic impact of the
tariffs in terms of paying down the debt
also worth noting president Trump's
blown out the deficit I know that we're
all supposed to pretend that there's
been a fiscally responsible
administration this has not been a
fiscally responsible administration I
like a lot of their monetary policy I
like I like the tax cuts I like the
regulatory policy they are blowing out
the spending the deficit is actually
increasing at a higher rate than it did
in the last years of Obama
so this talk about Donald Trump being
some sort of deficit Hawk is just
ridiculous and when he finally says that
this reduces taxes for our people
tariffs are literally a tax it does not
reduce taxes on Americans to make them
pay more for products tariffs are
literally a tax on the American people
so none of this makes any sense at all
and again it betrays what the president
actually thinks now there are people who
say well this is gonna come out in
Trump's favor because the fact that he
speaks so warmly of tariffs means that
other countries are gonna be afraid that
he will use them and then they will
lower their own tariffs okay well if
they come out that way then great but I
don't think that that's part of Trump
strategy I also don't think that's
necessary in order to get other
countries
lower their tariffs in fact one of the
best ways to get other countries to
lower their tariffs is to lower your own
tariffs because when you lower your own
tariffs what you're actually doing is
you are making it easier for your own
companies to produce advanced products
with the importation of cheaper products
from abroad so let's say we lower our
tariffs against foreign steel yes it
hurts the domestic steel industry but it
sure as hell helps the American car
industry or the American car industry
becomes a global leader because suddenly
it's a lot cheaper to produce that car
when you import cheap products into the
United States
I now save money that I can use to
invest in workers here at the Daily wire
right that sort of thing is how
economics works the fact that President
Trump is tweeting about all of this it's
just not particularly it's it's not good
stuff again mr. president if you would
just go to a basement for two years and
turn off your phone and watch just
replays of Shark Week all the time you
would be at fifty five percent the
approval ratings you enroute you would
win re-election easily what I don't like
is the fact that all this is happening
it's obvious is having an impact on down
ballot races if Congress goes the wrong
way in 2018 and we hear the revisionist
history about how it's the fault of the
media or about how it had nothing to do
with Trump or about how it was Democrat
lies or all the rest of the stuff listen
there are a few factors that are always
consistent in American politics the
media are the left and Democrats lie all
of this is true but the one factor that
has changed and that is undermining a
lot of popularity for Republicans in
swing districts is that the fact that
the president creates this feeling of
chaos and then he tweets out silly
things at a ridiculous rate that needs
to stop if you really want the president
to do well you should be rooting for him
to stop all of this okay time for some
things I like and some things I hate and
then we'll do a federalist paper so
things that I like so I've been very
critical of President Trump today but
one of the things that makes President
Trump very popular obviously is the fact
that he has an innate sense of of
nationalistic patriotism and that was on
full display yesterday
the motorcade was passing a bunch of
firefighters and and he decided to get
out of the motorcade and just go say
thank you to the firefighters which is
pretty awesome
thank you
what do you want to stand
Trump is a terrific retail politician
and he does have a gut-level loyalty to
cops and firefighters and soldiers and
that is a far cry from the former
President of the United States Barack
Obama who was constantly ripping on
police officers particularly he was okay
with fighters who and great with
soldiers either Trump has an innate
level of love for these guys and it
comes across that's why he stopped the
car and that is really good for him
obviously good for him I mean that's
that's I think how all of our
politicians should behave when it comes
to cops firefighters and soldiers okay
time for some things that I hate so over
the weekend on Watters world on Fox News
a show in which I've appeared there's
gonna be on swill yems black guy and he
was talking about Sarah Zhang's harijan
who we discussed last week and a little
bit earlier on the show is of course
this newest member of the New York Times
editorial board and she is egregious
right she's she talks incessantly about
how white people are ruining the world
she is a racist against white folks it's
very difficult to read her tweet to not
come away with that impression it's not
one isolated sweet it is legitimately
dozens and dozens and dozens of them
and Terrance Williams goes on Jesse
Watters his show and he launches into
what can only be described as a racist
attack on Asians which is just great I'm
glad that we've decided to do this now
so they're saying oh yeah some people
said some racist stuff to her so then
she said racist stuff back to imitate
them does that even make any sense
Oh mom that'll make no sense I don't
know no no no no it's something wrong
with them fortune cookies they Ling Ling
is eatin that cheesy it's not our
Terrance I think you now got yourself in
trouble okay so what what's funny about
this the only thing that's funny about
this at all because the joke is not
funny the jokes terrible the only thing
that is funny about this at all is that
the left got really offended at this
after spending all of last week
explaining that racism by people of
color is not a thing that black people
cannot be racist but I guess black
people can be racist against Asians but
only under certain circumstances this is
the problem with the intersectional
hierarchy and when when you suggest that
there is that we can judge by the color
of your skin whether you are capable of
bad behavior or not first of all it's
unbelievably paternalistic second of all
it's
incredibly insulting to two black folks
and Asian folks and people of every race
to suggest that bad behavior cannot be
attributed to individual choices it can
instead be attributed to whether you are
a member of a victimized minority group
I will say that there is something
ironic about the left's getting very
very upset about Terrance Williams
saying this sort of stuff where they
would be fully fine with sarah zhong
saying the same thing about white folks
she's sitting on the New York Times
editorial board
I don't think Terrance Williams his
invitation is in the mail anytime soon
okay other things that I hate so Jeremy
Corbyn who's legitimately just an awful
human being he has now apologized for
the hurt caused by the Labour Party's
anti-semitism in Britain the Labour
Party is a far left anti-semitic party
that is basically embraced Hamas and
Hezbollah Jeremy Corbyn has explicitly
done so right he was caught on video in
2010 showing him at a pro-palestinian
rally and referring to camasta
terrorists as his friends and comparing
the destruction in gaza to that of
stalingrad and leningrad during world
war ii and here he is pretending the
labor part the Labour Party is not
anti-semitic I'm sorry for the hurt
that's been caused to many Jewish people
we have been too slow in processing
disciplinary cases of mostly online
anti-semitic abuse by party members
we're acting to speed this process up
people who hold anti-semitic views have
no place in the labor for people wall
dances medical views have no place in
the labour party except in their top
leadership because Jeremy Corbyn is in
fact a brutal anti-semite and the fact
that he is considered not so is just a
demonstration that if you're a leftist
you can get away with legitimately
anything on planet earth it truly is an
incredible incredible thing ok time for
a quick Federalist paper so every week
we'll go through a federalist paper we
are all the way up to Federalist number
40 so in this Federalist paper James
Madison is still attempting to defend
the fact that the Constitutional
Convention went beyond its original
mandate to alter the Articles of
Confederation so if you remember your
history there was something called the
Articles of Confederation that was the
first attempt to form an American
government it was too weak because the
centralized government didn't actually
have the power to tax really or gather
an army or protect the country and so
there is a Articles of convention
meeting and articles of confederation
convention rather in which people were
supposed to get together and change the
Articles of Confederation instead they
went beyond that and just scrapped the
entire thing
and here's Madison suggesting why that
was okay he says let them declare
whether it was of most importance to the
happiness of the people of America of
the Articles of Confederation should be
disregarded and an adequate government
be provided and the Union preserved or
that an adequate government should be
omitted and the Articles of
Confederation preserves so this sounds a
lot like the ends justify the means the
argument that Madison is making here
which is you sends us here to do one
thing we decided to do another thing the
products good to deal with it I don't
like this logic very much from James
Madison I think that when you are sent
for a particular purpose that you ought
to fulfill that particular purpose their
delegates they are not there to to
completely surpass that however this is
the difference between a Republican
democracy in a democracy that people get
to vote on every specific policy in a
republic you appoint people to do what
they see fit essentially and then
there's a referendum on what they get to
do so what is the final level of
approval for the Constitution it's not
that they didn't usurp and move beyond
their mandate they did usurp and move
beyond their mandate but the final
judgement is the American people
deciding whether something is good or
not and this is why you have to have
everybody when it comes to the
Constitution itself after the
establishment of the Constitution every
branch has to feel an independent need
to justify its own behavior along
constitutional lines and the American
people have to hold our representatives
accountable along those same lines
rather than just suggesting that
whatever they decide to do is is totally
fine right you have to constantly be
holding yourself to a higher standard I
don't think they did actually when they
form the Constitution of the United
States in this case maybe the ends did
justify the means but as a general rule
of thumb I think that the
anti-federalists who argued this were
probably on better footing then James
Madison was okay we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018